ερμανικό γιατρικό κέντρο γ μάλιστα πως προεκες πρόκηψε από μια ανάγκη την οποία έβλεπα να
υπάρχει στον τόπο που γεννήθηκα στη λεμεσώη λεμεσώς φωνάζουμ όλοι η λεμεσώς πετά η λεμεσός
άρχισε να πετά άρχισε να πετά όμως οικονομικά στην πιότητας ζωής και λα αυτά των
ηγίων ανθρώπο οι ασθενής και οι δύως η ογκολογική δεν είχαν την ανάλογή περίθεψη στη
λεμεσώ στην πάφων των υρίτερονγεογραφικών το μέατης πολεσμο και έτσι είπαμε να προσφέρουμε νεκή τις
υπηρεσίες στον τόπον που έχουν την ανάγκη οι ασθενής και έτσι ξεκινήσαμε βέβαια ξεκινήσαμε είδαμε
τι άλλες ανάγκης οι οποίες υπάρχουν και προσπαθούμε να τις εξελίξο μια πό τις ανάγκης
οι οποίες υπάρχουν σήμερα ακόμη είναι οι αλλογενής μεταμόσχευη μιελού των οστών καια τα εν
οποία οι ασθενής φεύγουν πάλι από την κύπρο εμείς το δεδημεοργήαμε το έχουμε νέτιμο εναπόκειται
στο υπουργείονηγείας να αξιοποιήσει γίνονται προσπάθειες από πλευρά αστεν αξιοποιηθεί από τεπουργιογίααι εδώ και να
χρόνο πάνωπό ένα χρόνο επέρασα τις επιθεωρήσεις του υπουργείογικείας τα καν τον οποία εκαναμε και
τα οποί μάλιστα της αξιολόγησε θετικότατα κα αυτή της θιγμή ακόμα υπάρχει ένα τεχνικών πρόβλημα
πάνωπου ένα χρόνων ότι δεν υπάρχει νομοθεσία